[Music]
thanks for taking the time with ending
this talk
so we I'm gonna talk about like how to
make a Big Data Platform and
specifically make it extensible so my
name is Reza I did my PhD in computer
science the University of Illinois I
bended over since 2014 so when I joined
ubirr it was like a steel start a small
startup company so our data was so small
that he was still fitting into a1 like
one big Postgres table but we saw that
the business is growing so fast the data
is growing exponentially so we knew we
had to invest in a big data platform and
this talk is actually a summary of our
journey towards building that platform
so the talk I'll summarize it with a
quick the the basic the talk is gonna
start with a small touch on how we get
started on the big building the big data
platform I'll start I try to spend most
of the time on the current architecture
and how we made it like basically
flexible enough to be extensible and
then I will touch on some of the ongoing
issue is what we are working on right
now and I'll try to wrap it up by some
of the key learnings from this journey
so oberst mission is to provide
transform transportation as reliable as
running water to everyone everywhere to
this end we are operating in over 700
cities across the world 75 plus
countries and with two million plus
driver partners and we're still growing
on the infrastructure side and data side
this means that we have huge amount of
data being generated on databases we
have to store and serve the those data
to the rest of the company internally we
categorize our data users into three
main categories so we have city
operators these are the folks the
underground crew that operate each city
so these guys there are several
thousands of them managing different
cities and these guys needs to run their
cities so they need ad hoc query access
to all these big data to be able to
answer different questions to make
decisions for their cities on the other
hand we have data scientists data
analysts these are the basically the
guys who
study the data in basically the trend of
data are there changes in data over time
so usually look at long period of times
and they try to find patterns that try
to test out different ideas the idea is
to basically find new products that we
can achieve new features or improve the
existing ones and we are having a few
several hundreds of those across the
comment a good example at least how we
should spend our marketing budgets or
how we can better forecast the demand
supply in different cities at different
times so these are the types of
questions that these guys try to answer
the third category of the used data
users at ubers are the engineering teams
these are the teams across the company
that build products that relies on this
data to serve a specific business needs
a good example is like for example fraud
detection or the incentive payments to
drivers or as simple as onboarding new
drivers or new writers so we also have
hundreds of engineering teams across the
company building products on top of our
data so the first or the first effort we
had in terms of building a Big Data
Platform
was basically in 2015 early 2016 that we
build like a basically big-dicked a real
big actor platform we had multiple
iterations before that I gave a talk
earlier in San Francisco in terms of how
we get here if you interested about
learning about the history you can
listen to that talk you can see this one
has a follow-up in that time it's most
focused on most people who saw on what
we currently have what challenges we
have and how we made it basically
flexible so this was the basically
fair's big data platform that you build
on the left hand side you can see
different data sources we have our
transaction on online data board these
these transactions are stored in some
online data stores mostly to assure that
based on some UAD so all this data we
also basically use Kafka as a message
buffer across the company it's like we
try to be standardize on that since 2014
and it was actually very popular across
the company and it was horizontally
scalable so we stayed with that so these
are the source of data that we received
from a different online board and we had
a bunch of email basically added a bunch
of spark jobs a bunch of ingestion
custom jobs to bring all this data and I
do
so the whole ecosystem is built around
hadoo we made a few decision at the
beginning one was we decided to not let
users transfer make any changes to data
when the data is being ingested so
that's why it's called il so we ingest
the data in the raw format as is the
idea was we ingest once and let users do
whatever they want in Hadoop in a batch
format so if they have any issues on
anything you ingest the data once it
reduces the pressure on the upstream
data sources at the same time if there's
an issue with the transformation you are
in the Hadoop for so you can actually
add more resources and run the show
faster so we ingest the data to and be
decided on spot frame box so that's one
of the only bests we put in 2014
spot was in early stages it turns out to
be a good one which is becoming popular
frameworks for batch processing we
enforce schema we decided to use park'
so we decided to be neither the columnar
file formats or data is basically have a
lot of columns it's like several level
level of nesting so we needed a columnar
file formats to store them in the
optimized most compact format in the
HDFS at the same time for serving the
queries column and file formats helps
you serve bit queries more efficiently
so we decided to go with parquet and
then we move all that modeling all the
transformation in with enojado
so you can see that the data lands in
Hadoop in park' format and then the
modeling happens here on the quarry side
we open up the view query engines to the
user to decide which one they wanna go
bead on one hand we have hive which is
like basically the workhorse is always
good good to have a reliable querying
gene that can run the query net
regardless of the volume of data we also
provide support which basically for
users who need programmatic access to
the data they can use spark frameworks
to play around with the data and we also
added press to our notebooks presto it
was geared mostly towards the users who
need interactive coins and notebooks is
mostly geared towards a data scientist
at the same time so this is for all the
users one access the data and run
queries against hadoo directly we also
have those city ops that needs to run
queries but very small queries or mostly
on recent data and they
fast response time basically okay so
this was the first architecture our
first efforts towards building a big
data platform it's a very it's not
nothing like specific about it it's a
standard like data big data platform
that all the big companies build in the
Bay Area so I'll skip this one to save
some times I'll get to the big means so
with this platform we made Hadoop as the
source of tools for all analytical data
basically for the first time we had all
our analytical data in one place so
people had they different engineering
teams had their options to join these
data across each other they could go
back as much as they want so everything
in one place and this was this male
actually had a very popular across the
company the basic and because of that a
lot of new use cases start using Hadoop
at the same time it means ok more data
was needed to be ingested so the news
case were going up the data was going up
the scalability issues start showing up
and then but the good thing is most of
the companies in the platform were
scalable when I said scalable
horizontally scalable and to some degree
so it gave us some time to think about
what we need to build in long term to
give you some sense in terms of the
numbers so we are talking about a few
chains of petabytes of data in HDFS a
few tens of terabytes per day of new
data coming in or Hadoop cluster was
around like 10,000 because we had around
100,000 like batch of drawing per day
but again this was just the beginning a
bit more use cases more data
the whole thing was exponentially still
growing so one thing I escaped was the
fact that we build this platform it lets
us have all the data in one place we had
a few tens of petabytes of data it was
we were able to store them as serve them
to the users the only issue was the data
latency the data freshness was still
over 24 hours and the reason for that is
if you look at this picture
you can see on our data online data
store data stores at the left so these
are having for example let's think about
our trip statuses the trips gets stored
in these online transactional databases
and then the BMA stream of change locks
coming into Hadoop
so this stream of changed or keeps
coming in the problem was we had a lot
of updates so our data by nature has
a lot of updates on the historical data
Hadoop is basically most occurs towards
append-only
so you dump the data and then you deal
with that specifically we were using
park' which is a color modifier formats
so you can go and update a single record
in your previous files so what we had we
had to find a way to absorb all these
updates in one shot the way we did it
was we basically used HBase in between
what the way we were doing it was we get
a stream of these change talks we were
updating these records in HBase and
every few hours we make a new snapshot
out of HBase become birthdate to Parque
bring it into Hadoop swap the two tables
this was working fine
the problem is like basically you are
ingesting the whole data set because of
some changes so when we started in
January 2016
these snapshot creation and park'
conversion was taking around six six
hours with Hadoop becoming more popular
the data starts going we soon a few
months with the job is running ten hours
with double the amount of resources so
it was not scalable and because of that
the whole thing was taking basically
true like we couldn't ingest more than
once or twice per day and then on top of
this you have the modeling when you have
your source tables like ingest a
snapshot your basic is swapping the
table with a new one every 12 hours
which means your modeling has to happen
again from scratch so you have to do an
another snapshot modeling and at the end
- so the whole thing resulted in more
than 24 hours data latency for the users
this was a big achievements we have all
the data in one place but the data was
basically too slow for our use cases
Uber's use case by nature is very
real-time cities need to make decisions
very like very few minutes or few hours
they can't wait for 24 hours for new
data to ära
so this was one of the big big concerns
and feedbacks from the user that we had
to address this so if you want to
summarize the limitations from our first
data platform a big data platform effort
first thing is scalability as I said for
example HDFS is scalable what scalable
means to some degree you can easily use
it out of the box for 10 20 petabytes of
data beyond that it starts showing all
these limitations you will start seeing
all the small files taking putting a lot
of pressure on the name nodes at the
same time or ingestion jobs but also
spark jobs that people were rhyming
writing to get the data in so it works
fine and you have a few hundreds of
tables to be ingested a few thousand
when you get above 10,000 20,000 you
can't have custom jobs ingesting the
data it's too fragile the operational
overhead is way too much at the same
time the data latency was too high so we
had 24 hours a wait time for the users
to get fresh data updates was becoming a
problems at the same time you have late
arriving data what if a trip takes much
longer than we expect to show up at the
source then we had late arriving data
and this was basically causing a lot of
problems for the system at the end and
finally the ETL was also snapshot so our
ingestion route data ingestion was
snapshot it was 24 hours and then ETL
has to have an effort that so it was
basically very problematic so these
these were main ideas that we were
trying to redesign our architecture the
the second one that the currently are
used running a production to give you
some sense in terms of the numbers that
we were talking about so in early 2017
we had several hundred petabytes of data
in HDFS or Hadoop cluster was growing to
a few hundred thousand because there
were several hundred thousand batch jobs
and careers running their daily basis
and again this business was going to be
this is that time that we introduced
like uber each was basically taking up
so if you want to consider I can
consider that we had the uber trips
going on and then we were each was
adding up who were afraid was coming up
so there are business new businesses
coming in and the amount of data was
still growing exponentially so the main
motivation was at this time we saw that
for the first time okay we have some
Headroom to to study our datasets and
decide what we really needs to build
something that's extensible and
something that's gonna last us for long
term so the main imitation that we were
trying to address first was HDFS
scalability so this again that almost
all the companies who has data beyond a
few things of metal eyes would start
seeing these problems name was is almost
always going to be the root cause for
this the problem the good thing is this
is a known problem so a lot of company
has faced this problem before so there
are it's noticed its easy solution it's
not an easy problem to fix but it's a
straightforward
problem to fix so you can follow the
experience from other companies
basically you have to use some way of
federating your name notes there are
different ways to do that but by
separating your namespaces you basically
do spread the nameless pressure across
multiple boxes instead of one and then
that gives you head rooms it lets you
scale beyond a few hundred terrible
petabytes so I skip the details here but
they have a nice engineer block on this
if you are interested what little as you
can go and read that the second priority
we're having was basically people all
our use cases within the company they
need fresh data they need the data to be
there as fast as possible at the same
time we knew that our data set has a lot
of updates and deletes and we need to
address those within HDFS and on top of
parquet at the end I got this question a
lot that why didn't you replace part
here is something else because again our
dataset is extremely large we have a lot
of columns in each data coming in we
have five six level of nesting data so
there is no way to bypass the column our
file formats we can replace parquet with
something else but it's the same problem
you still have to address the update and
delete issues on top of those column or
file formats and finally we had to make
our ETL more efficient we can't keep
doing snapshot based ingestion snapshot
based I'm modeling we have to make those
efficient and fast and we have to move
the incremental model so oh this is a
good slice for to fully understand what
I mean when I said our dataset when I
looked at those and studied those we saw
that by nature they have updates so
there are companies that they have data
coming in for example user click star
these data when they say of this is
mostly late-arriving data or data set is
we're actually having real updates so
think about our tube statuses when a
trip happens this is like the data sets
the source data sets at the left and you
can see the Hadoop data on the right so
we ingest all that they had trip status
or inter hadoo the partition those based
on the trip dates at day level so most
of the trips are new trips these are the
new ones the the green bars that you can
see that are added at the end so the new
trips easy new trips gets added at the
end the problem is like for example like
me you you have a trips happening for
you today
the ferries I say 15
so that gets recorded as a green box
then you have a problem with that shape
so you support the sub you submit a
support ticket they look at it you say
oh if there's something wrong so they
change the price back to they say $5 but
this is an object it can happen like the
trail change that usually happens within
a few days what it can happen is
basically on the longer time base for
example riders the rate their drivers
next time they take care of it so if you
don't take a ride every day if we take a
ride every week every month you're gonna
rate your driver from last month it has
to be so you're gonna have an updates on
previous trips data based on the nature
of the data and this is these orange
boxes that I'm showing here obviously
the amount of updates keeps going down
as you go back in time but there's a
long tail of updates six months one year
we see updates happening a one year ago
all the time so how did we do that we
introduced a new basic product a library
called hoo-dee-hoo D stands for Hadoop
absurds
and then it incrementals it's a
basically a storage abstraction that
lets you do two things first it lets you
apply absurd and delete on top of the
column our file data of Parque in HDFS
well second thing it lets the you think
about the users who needs to read this
data out so one thing is to be able to
absorb these updates and delete that are
coming in the second thing if you are a
user I knew if there is an update and it
rips from let's say one year ago how can
the user know about that the users can
keep doing the full table scan and
finding all these updates that's a very
expensive query operations so what we
want to provide them is something called
incremental pool which means on the user
side and the reader size they can pull
out only the change data regardless of
when that happens in time so even if you
have one trip from one year ago updated
users can fetch only that one record
without scanning the whole table so
these are the two functionalities that
help today who do you I believe provides
it's a spark waste library so it's
basically scale it horizontally scalable
it only relies on HDFS to operate so you
don't need any other dependency on HDFS
and it's open source so if you are
interested in trying it out you can
check the code at github
we have a blog post on that and we gave
a lot of talks about the details so feel
free to check it out if needed so now
let's look at have a look at the data
architects the platform after we
introduced 2d and we moved from snapshot
path ingestion to incremental on the
left you can still see the data sources
and so there's a stream of change now
coming into Kafka
so we standardize on Kafka as the
handover between the online databases
and the analytical boards so you have a
batch job ingestion jobs that runs let's
say every 15 minutes 10 minutes and it
gets these change logs the good thing is
with Rudy it can now go and update the
previous data it doesn't need to
recreate the whole table and strap the
tables so hudie allows us to basically
reduce the ingestion time from over 24
hours to basically to 15 to 30 minutes
the first effort we start with 30 now we
are running at 15 minutes and we are
aiming for 5 minutes by the end of the
year so that's on the ingestion of the
raw data
Dean Dan on the modeling side so same
thing so the modeling jobs can
incremental II pull these changes only
the change data using the hoodie readers
out of the hadoo and they can actually
go and update the previous table using
hoodie writer with the same approach
so end-to-end data latency was reduced
from over 24 hours to less than 30
minutes for raw data and one hour for
the model as I model tables and the data
size was growing from from 10 petabytes
to over 100 petabytes ok so
traditionally again once you ask it in
the introduction was the fact that like
Atlanta architecture you're familiar
with there's a streaming part there's a
batch part so we also have the same
thing we have a streaming services we
have the batch horse I was mostly
focusing on the batch words and the part
that I am focusing on is they're
basically the space between these two so
the problem with the lambda architecture
is users are confused when to use
streaming when to use batch there is a
blurry line in between there by default
everyone knows if you need for example
one minute two minutes to access the
data you go with
dreaming if you can wait a few hours and
then access the data you go with batch
but what about the use cases a wide
range of use cases are lying between
these two so these are the use cases
that we are trying to target and we call
this approach incremental and mini batch
processing so in the use case between 5
minutes and 1 hour is a perfect use case
for this you have the power of batch
which means your job is running as a bad
job you have access to all historical
data so the streaming side you have to
know the queries ahead of time and you
basically the query expand the query
class itself aside the execution the
processing class itself is pretty high
because you have to process the messages
one at a time you have to scan the whole
data so it's pretty expensive in terms
of running the query the good thing with
batch and is that you're running on top
of column of five formats so you only
read what you need and with incremental
fetch you can only fetch out the change
data the part that you care about so
this is the the a the wide range of use
cases that we that we were trying to
focus on okay so and yeah so basically
any query that you want to run
regardless of whether you are there
streaming or batch you should consider
three things one is what's the latency
for the data to be there
what's the completeness of a data you're
running against and what's the cost of
that what's the hardware cost to run
that query against and if you look at
these three parameters you can basically
break down all different use cases that
you have with with the pure streaming
use cases pure back traditional batch
jobs and most of them fit in between
somewhere in between which we call them
incremental mini batch processing and
the other thing that we did as part of
this new architecture was the fact that
we try to standardize everything one
issue that we had before was we had a
lot of ad hoc custom jobs for ingestion
of a data how are we basically expose
the data to the users as part of the
redesign the architecture we try to get
rid of all these exception we try to
standardize everything one thing we did
and turn out to be a good decision was
the fact that we standardized a raw data
model so I keep mentioning that these
online data stores they they provide us
with a stream of change
look at this for example we have the
rocky one column one value a and B at
time T 1 we get column 2 value B
according to value secon led so at the
data stores at their upstream data
stores depending on when you look at it
you can see different values for column
a and B on the specific key when these
stream of changelog gets into hadoo we
provide two standards basically hive
tables data models one is one we call
change la history table this is the
history of all these change locks and
the other one is a merged snapshot table
that only that depending on when you
look at it it always shows you the
latest merged snapshot values the good
thing with this approach is that the
users will care about the specific
column or who cares about the changes of
a specific column can have access to the
change lock history table and the one
who cares about the latest value can go
and use the merge snapshot tables and I
want additional feature that hooda
provides is the fact that it's basically
it provides atomic transactional
exposure of data so you ingest one batch
of data and it doesn't reveal it to the
users till you basically do a submit
so it basically you can absorb a bunch
of data and basically reveal it to the
user all at once and with that we can
have snapshots that are moving in
batches so we have basic it's the same
thing as in VC model another improvement
that we did to the platform as part of
the redesign was to get it up all those
custom ad hoc spur jobs again it was
working fine when we had a few tens
hundreds thousand tears when we had over
twenty thirty thousand tables to be
ingested we can't have custom job to
ingest that first it's not scalable the
operational cost is basically very high
and second and they are very fragile
anytime there is a schema change or
something the jobs are breaking so we
had a team of a huge number like 10 20
people's basically just fetch and
patching this stuff and there were
always complaints from the users because
the jobs are fragile and always break it
so one thing we did it was to get rid of
all those basic custom jobs and build up
frameworks that basically it provides a
generic any-to-any data platform a datum
of era so you
this is one mistakes that a lot of
company makes that they don't
distinguish the 15 ad hocs pork chops
and a platform when you say a platform
you have no room for exceptions which
means you difficult plugins to connect
the different sources and to cover in
two different sinks and then you get a
data flows regarding regardless of how
many tables are flying or flowing so
using this plant frameworks we basically
provide to services to the rest of the
company was what well one was the
ingestion that brings all the data from
all these different sources into Hadoop
and the second one was the data
dispersal that lets users take the
derive data sets whatever they generate
in hadoo back to the online they first
stores if they want to serve live
traffic think about for example the case
of uber eats so they have online
transactional data stores that any order
gets recorded there they bring this data
into Hadoop they run a machine learning
model within hadou to generate
recommendations or users based on the
previous interaction and I think daily
basis and they take that model out using
the dispersal frameworks back to their
online data stores so they can serve
live traffic next time the users log see
so this provides a base to give
end-to-end comprehensive solution that
you can give the user flexibility to do
whatever they want we build the
infrastructure that users do whatever
they want on top of that okay the good
thing is this is any and we try to open
source as much as we can so as of a few
weeks ago we have also open source or
these any-to-any data a move around
platform it's called memory if you guys
want to check it out is available on
github we just publish the engineering
blogs on that and we gave a talk at
strata if you want to look it up give it
a try so it's pretty early stages but we
are aggressively pushing for that so if
you need a platform to move stuff around
give it a try
it provides both in just into Hadoop and
dispersal out of Hadoop and it's very
pluggable so you can add your own
specific source or your specific sink
and it moves the data between those two
for you transparently it's based on
spark
so it's a horizontally scalable and it
runs on top of Hadoop pool okay so okay
so now let's look at some of the
problems that we are currently dealing
with first is like data quality I
skipped a lot of stuff about schema part
we invested in enforcing schema from
2014 from the very early stages and it
turns out to pay very well for us
because when the data gets into Hadoop
is as high quality the problem is we we
only have schemas enforced on the format
and type of data for example specific
field has to be integer that is very
basic guarantee that we need to get the
data in our current effort is trying to
move beyond the type and structural
check towards the semantic checks which
means for example if you have a feel for
a tree it can't have a negative value so
if I define it an integer it doesn't it
doesn't enforce the fact that it should
be a positive number so if you are
moving beyond that this was a very basic
ones but you are moving beyond and type
and structure object to semantic checks
at the same time we used to have two
traditional words it's very typical at
all the companies that they have an
online holds and they have an analytical
offline words so the problem is the link
between these two are most of a time
broken what we are right now focusing on
is trying to unify our basically service
RPC the ARP at the online board with the
analytical voice both in terms of schema
and how they interact with each other's
so these would significantly improve
your data quality the other issue the
other efforts that we are working on is
in terms of providing faster data so I
keep saying that okay we move from 24
hours to 15 to 30 minutes at this point
but our users are actually needing more
fresher data specifically with moving
more streaming jobs to part these
interactive batch mini batch mode the
users need more and more fresh data so
we are basically focusing on new
who the improvements to bring the data
latency down to five to ten minutes
the next big monster is the efficiency
so with your data growing the hardware
cost starts going up so you will get
very like chunky builds in terms of the
hardware cost and so you need to invest
in improving the efficiency and and
again we try to improve our data storage
format or ingestion just so we did all
the stuff one thing that we are focusing
right now is to increase the utilization
of our heartbeats yarn usually takes
care of the Hadoop resource management
for you we also use misses for our
online transaction on online services
what we are working right now is to have
one unified resource scheduler that can
work with in Hadoop and across all these
online services we are planning to open
source it I think next year so it's
called pallet zone which basically is a
unified resource scheduler that works
both for Hadoop as well as the other
services running also had so there is
again we have another talk on that if
you want to check it out
who is we're still in actively
developing it again we are aiming for
larger park' files so right now you're
basically getting to 1gb files we want
to go beyond that again HDFS had name
node issues so there is a cost with
having small files so the larger files
the less pressure on the name knows a
more scalability with in HDFS at the
same time we want to basically be more
efficient in terms of absorbing the
updates so that means if I have time to
get that so I give a quickly pass on
this slide I'll give you just a taste
but we can talk about in the episode
afterwards if you have questions so
basically what we have in hoody
internally it's a technology called I
call it copy-on-write
which means you have this Parker files
at the core Parkay files or append-only
sorry it is read-only so you can't go
and update or append to those what we
did is when there is an update we create
another copy of the files we absorb the
updates while writing the device and we
version these facts and then we this is
how we initially absorb all these
updates with including the problem with
that is you want to have larger park'
files so your 5 stars
from 128 225 256 megabytes and 1gb so
rewriting a whole file because of one
Records being updated is very
inefficient it actually increases your
write amplification this is where we
started but what we are going right now
is a technology called measure B which
basically means you have these basic
parking files you start having Delta
Phi's next to those you put all these
updates and deletes to do the Delta
files and you merge these two and do an
asynchronous compaction only when you
have enough data in the Delta Phi to
justify the rewrite and this is what we
are kind of working on at the same time
you're adding global indexing to hoodie
so hoodie by default has some solution
of indexing per partition we are
expanding that to be a global indexing
across all the partitions so I'll skip
this to get to the lessons learned okay
so it turns out the essence now and this
is I think one of the it took us several
years to learn this stuff so I hope this
is the main takeaway for you guys for
attending stuff the first thing is you
need to study your data we learn it the
hard way you need you can't build again
I was working at Apple Twitter so a lot
of other folks work at other companies
so we had been we knew how to be the Big
Data Platform the problem is you can
just copy a data platform from one
company to another company it works to
some extent it's not the optimized long
term solution for your company so you
need to find the time study or data or
studied update the way the data is
accessed and design a solution based on
that you can obviously borrow ideas from
other solutions other companies but you
can't just copy the whole architecture
over so again the good thing is for us
is when we spend time studied our data
we build the platforms on top of the
incremental ingestion incremental
processing of the data that opens door
for us to support unexpected use cases
for example gdpr came out after tests so
a beacon require so we build this
platform before gdpr was even being
discussed so the good thing with this
approach is when you have the right
primitives when you can absorb update
and delete and something like gdpr comes
in so you don't need to be worried about
in our use case so they were talking
traditionally all the companies they
dumped all the Daytona do they deal with
it later
they basically get rid of it with
retention some sort of attention or they
just let Italy and live there and they
don't touch the data with GDP all you
have to go and clean up the old data you
have to go and delete and update or of a
scattered data so we take pass having
the right primitives having the
capability for the users emit data users
inside the company to update the delete
data all you have to do it to provide
these primitives to the earth security
team and they were basically able to go
and update clean office scale all the
historical data so this is like why it's
important to understand your data the
second takeaway is data quality is
always an ongoing air force you have to
emphasize on that from the beginning
it's not some second if the problem that
you tackled down the road you have to
start investing on that from the
beginning this is the main distinction
between having a data swamp when you
have tons of data you can make sense out
of that we compared to an effective data
like something that you can use on daily
basis can make the database the
data-driven decisions in an effective
ways so one key component of that is
enforced schema as early as possible we
did a good job in defining a mandatory
schemas from the beginning it helps us a
lot down the road to encourage users to
use the platform because the data in
Hadoop was of high quality it was super
easy for them to use them but don't
limit yourself to just mandatory type
schemas think about like higher level
semantics how we can enforce like more
more granular semantics on top of these
schemas again try to have take
documentation very seriously so it's
easy to say I've defined these schemas
when you have a few hundred tables when
you get to twenty thirty thousand tables
these schemas are meaningless for users
that are using them some stuff mimics
may seems obvious from the at the
beginning okay the trip fare it seems
okay but then you start seeing the
business running in different companies
the currency starts changing so it's
becomes very problematic for the users
to know what to expect from the
so make the documentation for all these
schemas mandatory try to standardize
everything again then the moment you may
let the first exception happens you're
opening the door to a bunch of other
exceptions to follow that do not make
exceptions define your standard your
standard at the same time enforce them
and start educating users so use there's
a very blurry line between happy users
and like angry users so we had both we
dealt with both of them so the moment
again we provide the same platform it's
just how you educate your users if they
don't use it the right way they get
wrong answers they make wrong decisions
and then they start blaming you on
having poor low quality data so edgy
have your standard defined clearly
define and educate users in terms of how
they should properly use them invest in
the in enforce the retention policy we
didn't do that we started with saying
again let's have everything there we
deal with the retention later it's a big
mindset change for the users even if you
want to start with a very generous
retention have that basically baked into
your pipe as from the beginning so the
users know ok with there is a retention
for now it's time say 10 years forever
but at some point it may change based on
the cost of this data it's very costly
when you have raw data and all these
models they have data data copied in
Hadoop
at some point you have to make a call
and they get rid of some of the data and
if you don't have retention the idea of
all the data has some retention policy
from the beginning it's you're gonna get
a lot of pushback from the users and
when you want to delete the actual data
and track all your metadata metadata is
all the data about the data so who is
interesting what data was the data
lineage between these different tables
what is the data content who is
accessing this data the mert metadata
that you have later when you deal with
unexpected issues you can make more
informed decisions invest in a good data
pipeline monitoring so you don't want
users to report the problem the data
issues for you that leads to a several
hundred thousands angry users you want
to catch the issues before the users are
affected by that a lot of times small
data issues will not immediately get
reflected on the user size they will use
the data in
they make decisions that are not correct
and then later blames you because of
that so invest in the data pipeline data
monitoring define your terminology in
terms of okay what I mean I keep using
freshness and latency interchangeably in
this presentation these are very
different terms define it whatever
Matson Bay that makes sense for you
define a freshness latency completeness
data I mean data defined earlier
terminology and invest in the data
monitoring that basically gives you
visibility in terms of what you are
providing minimize your platform
dependency on user defined values again
you're almost always guaranteed for the
users to break the agreement do not rely
on that as a your in your platforms try
to move away from user defined values to
system defined values the good example
we were used relying on chips creation
time that the user were filling to
partition all data in Hadoop a lot of
times user left it blank or they put it
wrong values there and we had it go and
clean up and back through the data
remove a lot of that we rely on when
that trips basically happens at the
source gets recorded there is a few
seconds between the actual time that the
users puts on their vs. when that chips
is recorded at the source data stores
that is much less trouble compared to
the fact that we are relying on the
honest system defined values that is
more more reliable more robust and
long-lasting understand the last thing I
want you guys to take away is the notion
of time seems very obvious it's
basically when you talk about large data
set the data sets and like several
hundred tables is a very problematic for
the users to use the correct notion of
time so define what you mean by time in
different places your the notion of time
for different even between data partners
you have when that event happens when
the data was arrived when you process
the data or when you write the data or
when you use a query the data these are
all different notions of times make sure
you clarify this best as in terms of
times what you provide at each step
you